je vous le disais en commençant journal
notre invité ce soir et michel platini
et oui c'est en quelque sorte notre
cadeau de fin d'année à tous les
sportifs
michel platini si vous êtes annonce si
ce n'est pas pour jouer au football mais
c'est pour vous reposer je suppose oui
c'est pour retrouver l'ambiance
familiale
ça fait sept ans que je suis parti j'ai
pas jeter j'ai pas pu revenir
bon ça fait du bien de se replonger dans
l'ambiance de revoir les copains de foot
et tous les copains dans six mois michel
platini on a envie de vous poser
beaucoup de questions et effectivement
ça fait longtemps qu'on vous a pas vu
mais vous êtes je crois à rester lorrain
de coeur tout d'abord sur le plan
sportif vous êtes arrivé à saint-etienne
après n'avoir connu qu'un seul club en
fait nancy est ce que vous avez trouvé
beaucoup de changements et lesquels ben
je pense que les seules choses manche et
au niveau sportif on a on a une autre
dimension à saint-etienne qu'à nancy il
faut le reconnaître on joue pas les
mêmes on n'a pas les mêmes ambitions
nous on doit contre joue le titre
essayer d'aller plus loin possible en
coupe d'europe dans les canons sciés
bombe
il faut voir comment ça va se passer
puisque c'est difficile d'avoir à
disputer sans arrêt des matches au plus
haut niveau c'est à dire qu'on vous
attend partout en fait que ce soit à
domicile ou à l'extérieur et il faut
être toujours sous pression est ce que
ça vous a demandé une grosse mutation
sur le plan mental
non parce que déjà nancy j'étais quand
même attendu un peu partout
l'as saint-etienne c'est vrai on a on
joue des matches très importants toutes
les semaines m 2 fois par semaine et lcd
très difficile de toujours surmotivé
c'est pour ça on dit bowman
saint-etienne fait quelques matchs chez
lui mais on est obligé parce qu'il ya
une décompression est l'objectif de
saint-etienne cessé de jouer la coupe
d'europe
alors on se tait compresse un peu
pendant les matches de championnat vous
avez suivi bien entendu la crise
nancéienne bien qu'étant à saint-etienne
est-ce que
cela vous a touché qu'est ce qui vous a
le plus marqué l'avenir du club l'avenir
des joueurs où la querelle entre les
dirigeants bas à l'avenir du club avec
l'arrière des joueurs je pense
le choeur les dirigeants bon j'étais
très loin je ne sais pas vraiment bien
ce qui s'est passé mais j'ai quand même
des on me parle beaucoup au niveau des
joueurs et les joueurs sont un peu
perturbé parce qu'ils ne savent pas ce
qui va se passer ne savent pas qui
devait commander ils ne sont pas des
personnes sécurisante autour d'eux et
c'est pas très bien pour faire leur
métier
dernière question saint-etienne en coupe
d'europe bien entendu en quarts de
finale dès le printemps
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui me
motive beaucoup un joueur comme vous est
ce que vous vivez maintenant pour la
coupe d'europe
en dehors de la vie normale du club oui
on est venu avec enfin on est venu avec
johnny rep rang français l'équipe de
saint-etienne était important qu'on
arrive en quarts de finale parce qu'on
n'aurait pas compris pourquoi on serait
venu est on est on est très fiers et
puis on est un petit ouf de soulagement
quand on arrive en quarts de finale et
maintenant je pense que tout ce qu on va
prendre ça va être un peu un peu de rab
et et nous nous serions très fier si on
pouvait enfin remporter une coupe
d'europe on sent que la première équipe
en france mais c'est pas encore fait
dernière question
ça devient un feuilleton vous savez que
les frontières italiennes vont s'ouvrir
on parle périodiquement de vous à
l'inter de milan
est ce que c'est toujours aussi sérieux
ben les dirigeants de l'inter de milan
ont vu les dirigeants de saint-etienne
en début de saison et je n'ai pas
question pour que je parte inter de
milan à la fin de saison
j'ai encore un an et demi de contrat
après on verra ce sera tout dépendra les
propositions qu'on le fera encore à
saint-etienne dernier mot vous avez
offert un cadeau pour le noël des
enfants sont joie c'est un geste que les
sportifs ont certainement apprécié
est-ce que vous pensez que les sportifs
peuvent être associés dans ce genre de
campagne oui bien sûr
la preuve c'est que bon mais les
mélanges jour - joueurs ont fait un
match très important à dortmund 6 0
milles
la recette à l'unicef je crois que il
faut être solidaire un peu avec les
personnes qui sont très malheureuse et
notamment les enfants plus bombe à la
lorraine est une honte une région très
touchée par les problèmes économiques et
il faudrait qu en 81 sél et veut que je
souhaite que ça se passe beaucoup mieux
voilà c'est sur seven michel platini que
nous allons passer à la page suivante de
notre journal la première réunion de ce
soir à ce qui accentue longemer hier un
peu long ça fait quatre minutes
qu'attend tout en y compris transmet pas
moi moi je moi je trouve que c'est bien
parce qu'on a c'est bien ma pulsion
sucre à le canard sur le ski 1 on le
relit quand même wolin